sounds broken in 2018 the average
American will spend $600 on holiday
gifts and total spending in the US will
top 700 billion dollars and more than a
hundred billion dollars of that spending
will be totally wasted for his
economists like to say those gifts will
be a deadweight loss how can you avoid
such a loss this year economic theory
provides a simple solution give cash
Yale economist Joel Wald Fogle
conducting serious science wrote a
famous article that estimated that
between 1/10 and 1/3 of holiday
giftgiving is mismatched compared to a
cash gift
Walled Fogle finds further support from
economist Steven Landsberg who says he's
not sure why people give each other
store-bought gifts like clothing instead
of cash because cash is never the wrong
size or color so clearly cash is always
the most efficient gift but if cash
seems too impersonal consider the next
most economically efficient gift a gift
card like cash it's never the wrong size
or color do you think cash is an
acceptable holiday gift let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI